in the nfc
the playoff teams their fatal flaws
let's get right to it and by the way to
the extent that you're waiting for a
jets ravens preview
it's coming yeah this isn't a big
thursday night game i know it's the last
thursday night game of the year but it's
not a big thursday night game because it
features the jets all due respect look
the jets had their chance to be good
this year they're not they're playing
the best team in the league
we'll talk about it coming up for now
let's focus on the best team in the nfc
the san francisco 49ers as they reclaim
the one seed and move toward potentially
winning the division it's gonna come
down to a showdown week 17 against the
seahawks what is their fatal flaw man
there's not a lot of flaws on this
football team i mean you know again and
they barely lost the seahawks in a game
where their two tackles came back from
injury from a long time off and played
horrible uh of course stood toe to toe
with the ravens and it was a rainy
quagmire that hurt them i i think if i
had to go one and i'm not i'm not lying
here and this is not because he's my
friend or anything like this like i had
a hard time when you said when i saw
this last night on text on the rundown i
was like man what is the 49ers fader
fatal flaw i think the biggest one would
be to me to what weirdest ugly had a
little last week a little bit of
predictability on the defensive side of
the ball they need to change it up a
little bit more than what they do again
another team mike that you hear me talk
about a lot plays a seattle scheme and
you just get in certain formations and
certain personnel sets sometimes and you
know what to expect and you saw sean
payton knew what to expect a few times
and drew brees and company gashed it i
guess that would be the one thing i
would look at as far as uh being a flaw
and i think that's fair to say they gave
up 46 points against the saints the
possibility to have a defensive meltdown
is the fatal flaw because we've seen it
happen they gave up a lot of points to
the seahawks in that monday night game
they got they gave up a lot of points to
the cardinals both times they played
them they had gone through a stretch
before playing the cardinals where they
had given up like a total of 20 to 25
points in four games that all ended the
defensive dominance is over and the the
propensity the possibility that they
give up more than 40 points in a playoff
game is the thing that could kill them
because that may be a day they can't
score more points than their defense
gives up all right let's move on to the
packers currently the number two seed
what is their fatal flaw well run
defense all the way that's where i'm
going i mean i i i you know i beat this
drum all the time too the interior part
of their d-line is an issue you know
kenny clark is pretty good uh yes but
some of the guys that are in there
inside with him are just they're they're
not up to task and not great middle
linebacker play as well it's the 25th
run defense in football and that
compromises some of the things they got
to do in the past defense as well mike
penton's trying to juggle both of those
things together to make it work that to
me is the number one issue with the
green bay packers
yeah and i agree with you there and i
guess to find something else i would say
the inexperience of matt lafleur right i
mean we've seen a game this year against
the chargers where they were woefully
unprepared and aaron rodgers called out
generally the lack of preparation as you
get closer and closer to these games
where it's single elimination will he be
able to get it done against a better
team against a team on the road if they
have to go back to play the 49ers again
who just obliterated the packers on a
sunday night earlier this year can matt
lafleur hold it together when the season
is riding on the outcome of a game
that's going to be a question for me i'm
not saying that he can't but you know
for a team that is currently in position
to have the two seed i think that's a
concern yeah i i agree and mike you know
one of the things that jumped out to me
too is you know look at the packers
schedule you know that be one of those
teams that go who have they beaten i
mean i you could argue the two most
impressive wins of the year over the
first two games the bears and the
vikings i know they went to kansas city
and beat the chiefs but
the best player on the team wasn't
playing oh yeah that's right his name is
patrick mahomes so uh they're a team
that yes they're 10-3 and i got respect
for and i know it's aaron rodgers and
you know i love him and i think he's the
man but it's like i got questions about
a 10-3 football team about how really
worthy are they of the 10-3 record i
guess
let's move along to the saints currently
the number three seed they were the
number one seed before they lost at home
to the 49ers what's their fatal flaw
yeah i think they're i'm going to their
to their secondary uh that that would be
the big thing to me i mean you saw it
last week we've seen it a number of
times over the last few weeks in general
you know other than marshawn lattimore
he's the only corner they have that can
play man-to-man you know eli apple can't
trust him there pj williams can't trust
them there and therefore they uh you
know they get burned when they play
man-to-man and they have to play a lot
of zone coverage off of that i think
that's probably the biggest thing that
jumps out to me about the saints
yeah and i'm going to go with given
recent developments their run defense
because of the injuries to more
importantly sheldon rankins but also
marcus davenport you're going to get on
that defensive line and and if you know
if you want to grind it out against them
and keep the offense on the field make
the offense frustrated create a greater
sense of urgency when the offense is out
there
you're going to have the opportunity to
do it because you're going to be able to
sustain drives wear them down and uh and
you know try to win a game where both
teams are in the 20s instead of getting
into a shootout with a very def very uh
um you know dangerous offensive team
yeah mike i'm i'm with you there i mean
i think you know i was almost gonna say
that but but that plays into almost what
i said really i mean you know that now
the quarterback's gonna have a little
bit more time to shred that secondary
apart that's scary i mean davenport's
clearly their second best pass rusher
sheldon rankins is probably their best
interior interior pass rusher so now the
quarterback's going to be more
comfortable throwing the ball against
that secondary
those were big blows to that football
team this week
all right cowboys fatal flaws i don't
know that we have enough time in the
show to talk about all of their flaws
but what's the what's the biggest flaw
that can hurt the cowboys in the
postseason gosh
i i mean i don't even know where to
start here you know i know
well yeah i think you know a lot of it
does go to coaching to me
it's that's where it is on both sides of
the ball that's where it is you know
you've heard me just absolutely i can't
say it anymore defense is too
predictable they do the same stuff all
the time the offense is
good but the yards and their yardage
output doesn't like always translate to
points and things like that which is
also to me managing the game properly
that way to where oh this is a week we
need to lean on the run a little bit
more or this is a week we need to rely
on the pass a little bit more they kind
of seem to be off kilter there as well
too where they get a lot of meaningless
yards so
i guess that would be my my issue
i know it's become popular lately to
take aim at jason garrett and his actual
and perceived coaching flaws but you
ever noticed during a game
it really doesn't seem like he's doing
anything you ever noticed that like you
see belichick on the sideline with the
defense and he's got them all huddled
around and he's actively coaching them
during the game all i ever see is jason
garrett standing there
is that am i missing something well no i
mean the optics yeah you're you're right
there i mean you know i i wish jason
garrett would get involved more in the
offensive game planning and play calling
in general that's why he was hired you
know that i never like
when a guy was hired for one certain
thing and then doesn't do what he was
there to do to begin with like dan quinn
with the atlanta falcons we hired you as
a defensive coordinator and then he
didn't want to coach the defense anymore
he just
what the hell was that oh the defense
fell apart oh shocker we hired you to
coach the defense and now you're not
doing it so i don't really um i don't
understand that either i wish he was a
little bit more involved there
well and one of the reasons he got away
from calling the plays is he couldn't do
both he couldn't do the micro of calling
the plays in the macro of managing the
game as a head coach so he got away from
calling plays because it wasn't working
all right seahawks fatal flaw
past defense secondary i mean they don't
even have enough corners on their
football team mike i mean last week they
couldn't they had a hard time playing
nickel defense because they only had
three corners playing in the game i mean
the rams when i watched that film mike
they were playing four receiver sets
and the seattle seahawks were playing
four down linemen and three linebackers
i mean they'd have a guy they had like
you know going back to things we've
talked about like you know
kj wright would be covering robert woods
i mean they're just they're too
predictable on their defensive scheme
and they're not talented enough in the
secondary and that is an issue and
that's where i i worry about them versus
the nfl elite i know seattle's good but
i think the good offenses and the good
teams are gonna are gonna tear this
defense up unless you're deviant clowney
is a hundred percent and ezekiel are a
hundred percent and their defensive line
can take over games like we saw them
doing the 49ers game but that's the only
game
all year we've seen them really do that
and they're gonna have to do that if
they want to make a big run and get to
the super bowl
i'm gonna say their downfield passing
game because we for all the weapons that
they have yeah we really don't see
russell wilson air it out as much as
maybe he could or he should and you know
the big play against the vikings on a
blown coverage where xavier woods
thought he had or xavier rhodes thought
he had safety help even though harrison
smith was right in front of him and
david moore ran right by him you don't
see that a lot you don't see a lot of
shots like that i think you need to be
taking more shots down the field to
maybe soften things up and it just feels
like a grinded out offense and they
grind and they grind and they grind and
they grind and they score i want to see
a little bit more because between joshua
like they're not using josh gordon how
can you not be getting the ball more to
josh gordon he's a special talent sure
you've got him you've got tyler lockett
you've got dk metcalf i just and maybe
part of it is russell wilson's running
for his life before he throws the ball
and he sees something underneath and he
takes it but i just want to see the ball
up in the air down the field 30 40 50
yards more often well
they're not surgical in the past game
that that's probably their biggest thing
you know um i think that's the thing
that bothers me now russell wilson he
did not play his best game the other
night he certainly didn't you know hey
there was a few drops early on that hurt
them but uh it was one of the more poor
games i've seen him play this season you
know mike i i actually think they throw
the ball down field a decent amount
it's just there's not enough surgical
like five and 10 and 15 yard passes to
go along with it i think that's the
probably the thing that bothers me i'd
actually be really interested to look at
the numbers there exactly what what does
go on in their past game but i think
either way we're concerned about the
consistency of their past game the
surgicality of it if that's even a word
uh on a week-to-week basis
i i just want to see more josh gordon
and we know that josh gordon can do
special things and they were so thrilled
to get i mean between him and metcalf it
just feels like you got to be taking
more shots and that would make it easier
to do things underneath if you really
force the the defense look how many
times harrison smith was at the line of
scrimmage against the seahawks in that
monday night he was right there lined up
they waste plays they run they run into
bat into really good run defenses
sometimes and then they pass into a go
well the safeties are way book back why
are we passing there like really good
offenses wouldn't waste those plays into
some of the looks they do
all right speaking of the vikings fatal
flaw for the team that currently is
holding the sixth seed i'm gonna go with
i'm gonna go with the drop back pass
game the drop back pass game is where
i'm going to go it's run game it's blue
leg as play action you know that but
we've seen when you stop the run game
then the bootleg game loses his luster i
don't know if they're creative enough in
this the drop back pass game either
especially right now without adam
thielen to pick you apart that way uh i
mean i almost wanted to go with like
xavier rose in the secondary that way
but i think this is more of an issue to
me uh like if they play one of these
elite defenses in in the nfc playoffs
who can take away the run game is that
offense gonna be able to drop back 35 40
times and you know surgically destroy a
defense i'm not so sure about that
yeah now i i agree with you xavier
rhodes is an obvious flaw there and he
was off the field early in last week's
game i think the vikings realized he's
more of a liability than an asset at
this point right but but the the ability
of kirk cousins
to deliver the football when the walls
close in when the walls close in there's
nothing he can do he can't run away from
it
and it's just it's just over and and if
you can get him in a position where he
drops back and he doesn't find somebody
quickly uh it's over and you we've seen
fumbles we've seen sacks we've just seen
ugliness and we've seen vikings uh
drives and games fall apart when cousins
is under pressure and uh you know that
clock for him
uh has to accelerate and sometimes it
accelerates too much like it did in that
fourth and three play against the
seahawks with the game on the line from
their own 42. he got rid of the ball too
quickly because he was concerned about
the walls closing in on him and him not
being able to at least get the ball into
the air uh to try to extend that game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports